STEPHANIE WONG: Hey
everyone, and welcome
to the second episode
of AskGoogleCloud.
This is a show where we
solve humanity's greatest
mysteries, like did the
chicken or the egg come first?
Oh wait, hold on, no.
I'm actually being told that
our poultry experts aren't
able to make it
today, so we are just
going to stick
with Cloud topics.
I'm Stephanie Wong at Google
Cloud Developer Advocate,
and today I'm joined by Dale
Markowitz, an Applied AI
Engineer here at Google,
and Sara Robinson,
a Developer Advocate
focused on AI and ML
and I'm huge fans of you both.
So, Dale, Sara,
how are you doing?
Thank you so much
for being here!
DALE MARKOWITZ: Thanks
for having us, Steph.
I feel like I've been
seeing a lot of you lately.
STEPHANIE WONG: I'm omnipresent.
SARA ROBINSON: Doing
good over here.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well, I'm
excited to have you both.
Today, we will be
answering questions
submitted by you, our amazing
Google Cloud YouTube audience.
We're always looking out for
questions about Google Cloud
products, so be sure
to leave any questions
you may have in the
comments of our videos
using the hashtag,
AskGoogleCloud.
And if you have any other
questions that come up
as you're watching today,
then please go ahead
and type them in the live chat.
I think it's probably
somewhere over here.
And we'll do our best to
try to get to all of them.
We'll be hosting AskGoogleCloud
segments throughout the year,
so be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to get notified every time
a new episode goes out.
So with that said,
let's go ahead and get
started with
today's topic, which
is AI and machine learning.
Our first question comes
from Vedic_ who asks,
how do you get started with
AI/ML with a non-technical
background?
So Dale, let's go ahead and
throw this question to you
first.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I get
this question all the time
and my answer really
changes depending
on what you're going for,
what your background is.
As a developer-- which is
a technical background--
I always like to
tell people, you
should go at machine
learning by trying
to find a project that you
actually wanted to do anyway
that uses ML, and then just use
the simplest tool for the job.
So start with
high-level tools-- maybe
speech-to-text API, maybe a
pre-built image classification
model.
And then once you get the
feel for how ML is useful,
you'll be more motivated to go
in and learn TensorFlow and do
the nitty-gritty details.
But I'm sure, Sara, you
have thoughts on this.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah.
I think one of the cool
things that I've seen recently
is there's a lot of tools
that are just making machine
learning more accessible
to people that may not
have a technical background.
So things like
AutoML, which we'll
get into probably later on--
really help a lot with that.
DALE MARKOWITZ: There's
also a tool I adore
called teachable machines.
In fact--
SARA ROBINSON: I've seen
that one, it's awesome.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah.
It's like a way for
you to train a model,
like an audio or a vision
model, and it's like--
I had a 10-year-old
kid email me a model
that he trained using it.
So it's-- he's very smart,
but it is a very user-friendly
tool.
SARA ROBINSON: There's
also a great resource
called Machine Learning
Crash Course, which
is made available by Google.
It used to be just
internal training that
was used at Google, but we
made it public a few years ago.
I'm constantly going to
the glossary on that site
just to remind myself common
machine learning terms.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, that's awesome.
I mean, if a
10-year-old can do it--
although he is
super smart-- then
I feel like that's motivation
for us to get started.
And believe it or not, I was
always OK at math and stats
and I wasn't classically
trained in technical skills,
I guess you could say.
So, it's nice to know that
I can do machine learning
by using all of these resources
that you just listed online.
I think now, more than ever,
there is a plethora of things
that you can find.
DALE MARKOWITZ:
Well, Stephanie, I
don't think you should hold
other people to your bar,
because it's pretty high.
But I get what you're saying.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well thanks.
I mean, we all have to
start somewhere, right?
OK, let's go ahead and move
on to our next question, who
is from Crikxouba--
I think that's how
you say it-- who asks,
can you clarify what's the
difference between Vertex
AI and your old AI platform?
This is so confusing!
OK, I'm going to admit
that I was a bit confused
at first too, but it's actually
quite clear once explained.
So Sara, we'll go
to you for this one.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, sure.
So I've been getting
this question a lot
since Vertex AI was announced
a few weeks ago at Google I/O.
So basically, how
you can think of
it is that Vertex AI includes
everything from the AI platform
that you know, but it
also includes AutoML.
And the best part is
that it includes a lot
of new products for MLOps--
ML operations.
So, MLOps is
basically the practice
of productionizing your
models in a way that's
scalable and reproducible.
So the MLOps products
that are part of Vertex AI
include Pipelines,
Feature Store,
model monitoring-- maybe
some others in there
that I'm forgetting.
And then one of my favorite
parts about Vertex AI is that
whether you're training
a model-- it's AutoML,
or you wrote your own custom
model code in something like
TensorFlow or PyTorch--
all of those models show
up in the same unified UI,
and they can be deployed
to the same end points.
So it's a much more
streamlined experience.
We definitely
recommend that you use
Vertex AI for all
of your new machine
learning projects
on Google Cloud.
You can also migrate your
old models from AutoML, or AI
Platform to Vertex AI.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I mean, I've gotten
the question a lot too,
and I like to tell
people that you
can think about it like an
evolution of AI Platform
Unified so that--
like you said--
you have one experience in
interface for both AutoML
and creating custom models, but
it's all shared infrastructure,
data modeling UX, and API
layer so that you can quickly
move from data
science to production,
and it's useful for ML
novices with AutoML.
But then, as you become
more experienced,
you're able to manage
constraints and make
your own fine-grained
decisions with Vertex AI.
So, yeah.
This is exciting.
SARA ROBINSON:
Yeah, you bring up
a good point about experience.
So it's meant to enable you to
use ML, regardless of your ML
expertise.
So if you're new to
machine learning,
there's tools for you on
Vertex AI that you can use.
If you have more ML
expertise and are building
your own custom
models from scratch,
you can use Vertex AI as well.
It works across the board.
DALE MARKOWITZ: And just to
riff off what you said, Sara,
I think we've been thinking
about how you build
and deploy machine learning
models for a long time.
You need GPUs, you need
hardware, blah, blah, blah.
But the idea behind Vertex
is, if you're actually
going to use an ML
production, there
are all sorts of other things
you probably would find useful
that are not necessarily
the ML part-- like, keeping
track of your data sets
and how they've changed,
and what is your model doing
when it's making predictions,
keeping a log of how the
data distribution is,
and whether it's drifted.
The idea with Vertex is,
yeah, you get the model,
but then we get all these
other useful things that
integrate really nicely
in one spot and one API.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well, speaking
of integrations in one spot,
this is a perfect segue
Because our next question is
from Chiru B, who
asks, why would I
use Vertex Pipelines when
I can use Vertex Training
and Prediction--
all parts of Vertex.
So Sara, why don't you actually
start by answering that first?
SARA ROBINSON: First let
me start by describing
what Vertex Pipelines is.
So Vertex Pipelines
essentially lets
you run end-to-end
machine learning workflows
on Google Cloud using
Google Cloud infrastructure.
And you can write your pipelines
using popular Python libraries,
like Kubeflow Pipelines
or TensorFlow Extended.
And so a pipeline consists
of steps, or components.
So you break each ML task
in your pipeline down
into a series of these steps.
And so, one step might be
for importing your data set,
one step might be
for training, then
one step for
deploying your model.
So that's the purpose
of Vertex Pipelines.
And what you can do
is you can actually
have a step that would use
Vertex Training and Vertex
Prediction.
So say you have a model
that you're training.
You want to have one
of your components
use the Vertex AI
training service to train
your model at scale.
And then maybe you want
to have a step that
evaluates your model and
looks at a threshold.
So maybe you only want
to deploy your model
if accuracy is above, say, 95%.
So you can actually
add conditional logic
to your pipeline, and then
say check my model accuracy,
or you can define whatever
metric you'd like.
See if it's above
this threshold.
If so, deploy it to
Vertex Prediction.
But you can also use Vertex
Training and Prediction
on their own.
You don't have to
use it in a pipeline.
So what I probably recommend
is, as you're getting started--
prototyping, developing
your machine learning
models and workflows--
start by just using Training
and Prediction standalone.
And then when you're
ready to scale that--
and you've devised
what all the steps you
want in your pipeline to be--
then convert that
into a pipeline
and run it on Vertex Pipelines.
Hopefully that clears things up.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I also add--
I'm so sorry, Stephanie.
I also wanted to add
to what Sara said--
and tell me if you agree--
that I feel like with software
development, there's often--
especially developing
for the Cloud--
there's often this trade off
between how easy something is
to get working,
and how easy it is
to port between different
running environments.
So if you were having a
machine learning pipeline
running on-premises
in Kubeflow Pipelines,
you can move it from your
local on-prem environment
to Google Cloud more easily.
But it's probably more
work to set up pipelines
than it is to just use
Vertex's prediction service.
Maybe you get that
running really fast,
but then maybe that's harder
to remove from Google Cloud.
So, there's sort of this
compromise between portability
and ease of use.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, I
totally agree with that.
If I was building
something on my own,
maybe I would start by using
training and prediction.
But then let's say I wanted
to share it with you, Dale,
and Stephanie so that you could
run it on your own machine.
It's going to start to
get a little complicated.
I need to make sure that you're
using similar environments
and have dependencies set up.
So in that case,
I might just want
to create a pipeline that
each of you could kick off,
and we could track
all of the output
from that pipeline
across different runs.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, I
love the option to have
that collaborative approach.
And what I love about
Vertex Pipelines
is that it's giving you MLOps--
which we've touched
on and talked
about here-- aka applying
DevOp strategies to ML systems
so that you can build
and release code changes,
monitor systems and reliability.
And like you said, it goes
hand-in-hand with training,
because you can reuse
a pipeline's workflow
to train a new model.
So I love how it's
all integrated
into each of these parts.
Let's go ahead and move on
to the next question, which
is from Aravind
S., who asks, how
do I use image data with
natural language processing?
And we'll go to
Dale for that one.
DALE MARKOWITZ:
Interesting question.
There are a lot of ways
to answer it depending
on how you interpret it.
So one would be, is
there text in the image?
Because that's a
matter of maybe using
OCR to extract
the text, and then
you just have a normal natural
language processing problem.
But maybe you're
actually asking about,
what are some cool machine
learning techniques
to use images and text together?
I love this question,
because it's something
that lots of people are thinking
about in the ML space now.
Normally, we kind of
weirdly siphon the way
we think of ML
problems into here's
the set of video problems,
and image problems,
and audio problems,
and text problems.
But in reality, if you're
trying to take advantage
of data that's in the
world or on the web,
a lot of times what you have
is a multimodal data set.
You have images with captions
is one perfect example.
So, for example, learning
how to caption images
is one really neat combination
of these two modalities.
One trend that I see that's
exciting today is the ability
to find ways to use machine
learning to represent data--
like images and text--
so that what you learn
from text transfers
to what you learn from images.
For example, if you have a model
that looks at texts and learns
that usually, men are the
ones that have mustaches--
this is a very
contrived example--
you learn something
about the relationship
between facial hair and men.
Then maybe when
you see images, you
can transfer what you
read about in text
to the images and vise-versa.
So, basically, humans learning
from audio text and images,
and maybe machine learning
models can now too.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, so the next
question is from Pascal L., who
asks, how can you use
data from Google Cloud
Storage or BigQuery to train
models on Google Cloud?
I love this question.
So let's go ahead and
go to Sara for this one.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks, Stephanie.
So all of our services
across Google Cloud
are really well
integrated, which
makes it easy to import data
from other places in Google
Cloud when using it for
training models in Vertex AI.
So when you're creating a
new data set in Vertex AI,
you have a few options for where
you want to import your data.
You could either import a file
locally from your computer,
you could provide a link to a
file in Google Cloud Storage,
or you could even provide the
URL of a table in BigQuery.
So for those of you
that don't know,
BigQuery is our
enterprise data warehouse.
So you can connect
your BigQuery data set
to your data set in Vertex AI.
No need to download the
data and reupload it.
Vertex AI will handle
that integration for you.
And then one other
thing I want to call out
is we have a tool called
BigQuery Machine Learning.
So what this lets
you do is it lets
you take your structured
data in BigQuery,
and use that to train custom
machine learning models.
And you don't have to
worry about writing
that underlying model code.
That's all handled for
you by BigQuery ML.
You just choose the type
of model you want to use.
And one other thing
I'll mention is that--
related to services
being well integrated--
if you're using a Vertex AI
notebook or a hosted JupyterLab
Notebook solution and
all of your resources
are in the same project as
that hosted notebook instance,
you don't have to worry
about authenticating.
That's all handled for
you within notebook.
So let's say I want to take
my data set in BigQuery
and download that into a Pandas
DataFrame within my notebook.
I can do that easily using
the hosted notebook solution.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I think as a
lazy machine learning engineer,
I-- and surely
many other people--
underestimate how much
of a big difference
this makes when
your data is kind
of in the same place
as your notebooks,
and your notebooks are
hosted on the Cloud
and you don't have to be
constantly refreshing them.
It's really-- really
makes you more efficient
when it's all in the same spot.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
There's something to be said
about a seamless experience
without context switching and
the authentication built in.
It's integrated-- I think--
between Google Cloud
Storage, BigQuery, and Vertex.
You have options, whether
it's batch or streaming data,
pulling it from
Google Cloud Storage,
or using the console
or API to upload
from your computer
or Cloud Storage
and then make modifications
and start the training process.
So the next question is
from LG Good, who asks,
is it important to know
TensorFlow and PyTorch?
So, Sara, can you
answer this one?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, sure.
So the short
answer, I would say,
is that you don't
need know both.
You can choose whichever
one is best for the job.
There's definitely no harm in
learning both if you'd like to.
But both have really
active communities.
So if you need help with
issues you're running into,
there's a good chance you'll
be able to find support.
And the good news is that
both TensorFlow and PyTorch
run on Google Cloud Vertex AI.
So if you write
models in either one,
you can train and deploy
those on Vertex AI.
STEPHANIE WONG: Easy enough.
So our next question is
from Chibi C., who asks,
can I use Google Cloud to train
models and generate predictions
on text documents?
Dale, I have to go
to you for this one.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah.
Actually, we could
both talk about this
because just the other week, we
both talked about document AI
on the GCP podcast.
And so, document AI is a tool
for everything machine learning
and documents.
Whether something--
a paper document you
take a photo of
or a scanned PDF.
So it allows you to read
the text off of a page,
it allows you to
understand what text
means within the
context of a page,
like maybe you have a table.
Or, you have a
form, and you want
to understand-- this
is the field birthdate
and this is the value
for within birthdate.
So, yeah.
The document AI toolset--
I mean, I don't know, Stephanie,
what do you think of that?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
so, once again, we just
talked about this
on the GCP podcast.
And what fascinated
me about document
AI was that under the hood,
these pre-trained models that
are built by Google Cloud
are using computer vision,
including OCR and natural
language processing that
creates these high-value,
high-volume documents.
And then meanwhile,
on the podcast,
we also talked about
our knowledge graphs,
which validate and enhance
the fields in your documents,
and you can train and create
your own custom document models
and still have human interaction
with AI to ensure accuracy
when you need it.
Pretty cool stuff.
DALE MARKOWITZ: One of the
things that this reminds me
of-- now that you bring up the
knowledge graph-- is, I love--
I'm a Kindle person.
It's OK, I don't
need paper books.
And one of the
things that I love
about reading a
book on a Kindle is
if I don't know a
word, I click on it
and boom-- there's
the definition.
It's like, maybe
connected to the web.
Maybe I even get a translation
right there in my book.
Document AI enables
a similar thing
where, maybe I'm
looking at an invoice
and there's a business
with an address.
And I click something-- and
because of the integration
between the data on the page
and the Google knowledge graph--
I know, is this an
active business,
and what type of
business this is
by linking it against web data.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Right, it's not
just text anymore.
It's this window into more
metadata and information
beyond that, which
we can represent
through this knowledge graph.
So it's pretty amazing stuff.
Our next question comes
from Moe B., who asks,
could you give tips on
operationalizing ML models?
How would you go about
it, and based on what?
So, Dale.
How about we go to you?
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah, sure.
I'm happy to answer this.
I think your
biggest concern when
you have a model in
production-- there are a couple.
First of all, you
want to make sure
that the data that you're
making predictions against
is the same as the data
you trained your model on.
This is one of the biggest
places that people have issues.
They train their model
on some sample data set,
then when they get predictions
from the real world,
they're out of sync.
So when you're
operationalizing your model,
you want to, A, be able to
have a way to check for that.
To be able to automatically,
over time as the world changes,
check for a drift
between your training
data and the real-world data.
And probably also a good
way to deal with the fact
that the world
changes is to have
a way of collecting the
new data as it comes in
and you make predictions
against your model,
and then automatically
retraining your model
and updating it with new data.
So that's the first thing
that comes to my mind.
Sara, I'm sure you have a
lot of thoughts on this.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
I would add to that.
So everything you described,
you can do that in Vertex AI.
You can automate this workflow
using Vertex Pipelines.
And one of the
cool MLOps services
that's available as
part of Vertex AI
is called model monitoring.
So it lets you do
exactly what you
described, and detect drift.
So if the new predictions
that you're getting coming in
are different from the data that
you use to train and evaluate
your model, chances
are you'll want
to find an automated way
to get alerted about that.
So you can set up
alerts so that you'll
get notified when a
certain threshold is
reached to identify drift.
Then, you can kick
off model retraining,
do whatever you want
within a pipeline.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And this all kind of
speaks to this other topic
that we recently
had on the podcast,
which was responsible AI.
And to me, MLOps is this major
evolution in ML practices,
because you can not only
reduce the amount of time
it takes, but you can reliably
go from data ingestion
to deploying model
in production.
And, like you said, monitor
and understand your ML system.
It's reliable, it's
efficient, and you
get that explainability,
that transparency,
so that you can have these
healthier, more representative
practices and models.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, one thing
I actually forgot to mention
is one of the great
things on Vertex
AI is feature
attributions, which
are available for
different model types.
So for example, if you
train a tabular model
in Vertex AI using AutoML, you
can get feature attributions
which basically show you which
features influenced your model
prediction the most and what's
signaling that prediction.
So it really lets you
look under the hood
and have a better
understanding of how
your models are performing.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And you were able
to leverage some
of this for some of your past
projects, like the cooking one,
right?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
That was a fun one.
DALE MARKOWITZ: This is
Sara's project originally,
but she invented new recipes
using machine learning,
and then we kind of
riffed on it together.
You want to tell us about it?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
And you should all
check out the video
that Dale and I did on this.
Basically, what I did
is I've been baking
a ton during the past year.
And I started to notice that
baking recipes in particular
follow a lot of
distinct patterns.
So there's a specific ratio
of flour to fat to sugar
that makes a cookie
distinct from a cake.
So I wanted to see if I could
train a machine learning model.
To start out, I trained
a model to predict
what different
recipes were, starting
with just three labels--
bread, cake, and cookie.
And then, I wanted to see
if I could use this model--
tweak the features,
the inputs, play around
to see if I could
invent a new recipe.
So the first one I created
was this hybrid cake-cookie
that I called a cakie.
It was pretty delicious.
We attempted in the video,
and we also make a new one.
It was fun.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, you
have to check that out.
And I think you also
partnered with Mars
and did some things
with confectionary
and you made some
recipes with that too,
so you've done a
lot in the space.
SARA ROBINSON: Yes, big
fan of baking and ML.
DALE MARKOWITZ: You may be
the premiere baking, machine
learning expert I
think in the world.
SARA ROBINSON: It's
such a fun hybrid.
Yeah, the Mars Project
was really cool too.
Basically flipped the
model that Dale and I
described in the video.
Flipped that.
So instead of providing
ingredient amounts as input,
you provide what
you want to make.
So I would say, I want
a 50% cake, 50% cookie,
and it would tell you the amount
of certain base ingredients
that you need to make that.
There's a blog post on it.
We can provide a link.
STEPHANIE WONG: We might
need a spinoff show for you.
SARA ROBINSON: I'm up for it.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right,
so our next question
is from IDRL Indian
Drone Racing, who asks,
how can we use less
images to train a model?
So, Dale, can you help
us out with this one?
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah,
I think the question
is, how can we use less data
to train a model in general.
And also, do we even
need to train a model?
This is what I'm
always thinking about,
because if you follow
at all the projects
that I build using
machine learning,
I'm always trying to
avoid collecting data.
This is the slowest
part of the project,
this is the most error-prone
it prevents you from
prototyping quickly.
So I'm always wondering, how do
you get the most out of models
without finding data?
So the answer that
everybody usually thinks of
is something called
transfer learning.
To understand how
transfer learning works,
you kind of have to understand
that the way that machine
learning works in
general is not that
just that you're learning
from data to understand
how to do a task--
like, identify
dog breeds, right?
That a machine
learning model, when
it looks at tons of
images, not only is it
learning to identify
dog breeds, it's
also forming some understanding
of the world in general.
It's understanding that
animals have ears and two eyes,
and usually a nose in between.
So in addition to trying
to learn what your task is,
it's also representing
the world.
This allows you to take
a model-- an image model,
for example--
that was trained for
something completely
unrelated to
classifying dog breeds.
Maybe it's used to classify
all sorts of objects.
And then, you bring your own
data with your own custom task
and you tweak and you tune
that model to do what you want.
So you take the model
that understands the world
and you say, OK, but now, find
a way to do my specific task.
So this is transfer learning.
It's been used for a
couple of years now.
Most image models will build
on top of another image model.
But we're seeing this
even go farther now.
Like, for example, there's
sort of a trending topic called
one-shot learning,
where the idea is
I want to get a model to
do my own custom task,
but I'm only going to
provide a couple of examples.
I'm not going to provide
a whole training data set.
I'm going to depend on the
model being good enough
to be able to generalize.
And if you look at
models like GPT-3,
this is a text model, a really,
really good multipurpose text
model.
You can get this model
that was trained once
on one data set to write
code, write poetry, do
translation, be a chat bot.
So we're moving forward
towards these trends in machine
learning where can you
build a large model that's
really good-- that's so good,
in fact-- that you can use it
for multiple tasks without
finding training data?
That is my hope for
where we get to--
to answer the
question of how do you
avoid collecting
so much image data.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, yeah.
It's really exciting,
because I feel
like it's all about making
this more efficient,
and the upfront work less on
the people who are doing it.
And if I understand
correctly-- so,
transfer learning means
reusing a pre-trained model
on a new problem that
you're trying to solve.
So for image
classification or NLP,
this is a starting
point for you to help
develop a neural
network model on image
or these types of problems.
Because typically, there's
a lot of compute and time
resources required, right?
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah.
You can kind of think
of it as, imagine
you need a data
scientist to write SQL,
but all you have is
a software engineer.
But there's a lot of skills
that transfer between writing
SQL and writing Python code.
So, it's better to start
with a software engineer.
They're going to get
the basic concepts,
and then you can train them with
less time to do the other task.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right, well.
There's a lot
happening in the space,
so I'm sure it's going to
get easier and easier as time
goes on.
So the next question
is from Taha, who asks,
is TensorFlow.js
the way to go if you
want to do real-time computer
vision on the browser?
I really wish I could
do that with OpenCV.
So, Dale, let's start with you.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah, sure.
I guess you're asking
me because we've
talked about a
recent project I'm
working on with TensorFlow.js.
What I love about TensorFlow.js
and also the tools built on top
of it, is that it's just--
machine learning part aside--
it just has a lot of nice
utilities for collecting
sensory data from the browser.
Whether it's from the
camera, or for a microphone,
it has a library
structure to just hook
into that stream really quickly.
And so it just makes any sort of
real-time sensory-based project
much easier to build.
Have you have you guys
played with this at all?
SARA ROBINSON: I haven't
played with TensorFlow.js yet,
but I have been meaning to.
I'm excited about your
new project on it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Like a pet-cam.
STEPHANIE WONG: I'm excited.
They actually talked about
this in I/O pretty extensively
when they were
covering AI, so it
seems like it's something
that is to be focused on.
The next question
is from Diego N.,
who asks, how do I use AI
solutions in a small business
with a low budget?
So, Sara, can you
help with this one?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
This is a great question.
So the first thing
I'll mention--
and this is available across a
lot of different Google Cloud
Services, not just
limited to AI and ML--
is to take advantage
of autoscaling.
So for example, when you're
deploying a model, when you're
configuring the machine
type and the settings,
you can set that to auto
scale so that you'll only
be charged when you're
getting prediction
requests on your model.
And then if it's
not active, it'll
scale all the way
back down to zero.
But I will also
mention that AutoML,
which we've talked about a
bit, is pretty cost-effective
and a great way to start
prototyping and developing
models that could eventually
become your production models.
So for example, if you want to
train an AutoML tables model,
an hour of training-- which
I find usually gets me pretty
good accuracy--
costs $20.
And for video, text, and
vision, it's actually only $3
per hour of training.
Just found this out today.
Super excited about that.
Yeah, pretty awesome.
So another thing to think about
is your time is also valuable.
So if you're going to be
spending time spinning up
a lot of this
infrastructure, it might
be a better use of your
time to just use the Cloud.
Take advantage of managed
services to do that.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Yeah, I 100%
agree with what you just said,
Sara.
Zooming back from the skews
on specific costs of products
and compute time or whatever,
the most expensive thing
that you could
possibly spend money on
is probably buying a set of
PhDs or a data scientist, right?
SARA ROBINSON: Totally.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So the way
you can really save money is--
especially when
you're starting off,
when you're building up
totally from scratch--
use the pricier tool if
it's way easier to use.
Build out the prototype, and
then bring in the experts
once the proof of concept works.
SARA ROBINSON: Right,
because chances
are you want to focus
on your machine learning
skills and improving and making
sure your data looks good.
And using managed
services really
let you focus on the
core of your machine
learning tasks, rather than
spinning up all that compute.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
I totally agree.
I can't overstate the importance
of getting up and running
quickly, and then
utilizing managed services
and moving towards that
progression of hiring
the right people.
And, like we said
earlier, Vertex AI
is that platform
that you can continue
to develop and progress as your
business gains more resources.
So unfortunately, that's
actually all the time
that we have for today.
So, Sara and Dale, I
want to thank you so
much for spending time with us.
Before we wrap up
completely, Dale--
do you have anything
that you want
to leave with the audience?
DALE MARKOWITZ: I just
really, really want
to know what people
are working on.
So if you have a machine
learning project,
please tell me about it.
Tell me about on Twitter.
If you disagree with anything
I said, pick a fight with me.
I just-- I want to know
what you're thinking.
So, thanks for having me, Steph.
STEPHANIE WONG: All
right, she said it.
She is willing to
take a fight with you.
So, Sara, how about you?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, I would
echo everything Dale said.
And also, I want to add, I'm
working on building out some ML
tutorials and I'd love to
hear what kinds of tutorials
you want to see.
So please drop a
note in the comments,
and let me know what
you're looking for.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And I think we'll try to include
some links in the description
today and after
today, and we're going
to be responding
to your questions.
So thank you, everyone,
for joining this episode
of AskGoogleCloud live chat.
We hope that your
questions got answered,
and we are going to
be back with more
of these live chats
throughout the year.
We'll be featuring your
questions from YouTube,
Instagram, Twitter, so
send in your questions
using the hashtag
AskGoogleCloud and comment below
if you have a question that
we didn't get to today.
I want to thank you
all for watching,
and we'll see you all next time.
Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]